get out
p-f-t-o-t tuesday edition where chris
sims and i have a chance to talk about
things we didn't get to
during two hours of pft live and chris i
am throwing
what you would call the owl river on
challenge flag on you one day later
than
i could have or should have because we
did a draft on monday of the best backup
quarterbacks in the nfl and you picked
nick foles and i kind of threw the
challenge flag then although i really
have the ammunition to back it up i now
do because falls is not the backup
trubisky is the backup and case in point
the folks at fanduel have installed the
odds as to who will be the starter for
the chicago bears in 2020 nick foles is
a minus 320 favorite which means you
have to bet 320 dollars to win a hundred
conversely for mitchell trubisky you bet
100 you win 200 if he's the week one
starter foles is the starter
not true bisky so you've lost the draft
one day after the fact oh too late too
late the time's laps do you or you can't
go back and change it now uh well
listen
i've been saying this over the last or
ever since they signed and you know
traded nick foles and got the new
contract they got to start nick falls
they have to
to me it's like a no-brainer all right
first off i just look at it and go
man mitchell trubisky is one of the
lightning rod subjects in all of
football and especially with the bearish
fan base and i think that he is of
course we know under a microscope
because of the desean watson patrick
mahomes thing and you know not you know
didn't play well last year there's no
doubt about that no i would certainly
sit here and argue that that offense in
chicago stinks too and a lot of
quarterbacks would have struggled in it
i would but i just think the way it's
stacked right now
man if you make mitchell trubisky the
starting quarterback to start the season
i just feel like it's a no-win situation
for the guy i do the first time he
throws an incompletion or the team loses
a game even though he might play well
it's going to start the blue birds or
let's start nick foles so i almost feel
like the bears have to start nick foles
and then if mitchell jabrisky was to
play it's okay we bring him off the
bench whether nick foles gets hurt or
not playing well and bears will be able
to digest that i think easier than
trubisky starting and them just wanting
him to be replaced by nick foles who's
won a starting quarterback and that you
know i think a lot of people just think
he's better than trubisky altogether
i vividly recall chris when we were in
chicago in advance of the week one game
for the 2019 season between the packers
and the bears there was a palpable sense
there was fear the fan base was like
what is going to happen with this guy
they were all scared to death that he
was not going to be the guy that we got
glimpses of in 2018 and they were right
they knew better than anyone they had
reason to be concerned about mitchell
trubisky we saw the regression last year
and you're right they can't start him
week one the only way it's not false is
if foles gets injured during training
camp or the pre-season and they have to
start trubisky because they just they
can't justify it now if foles does get
injured and trubisky gets a chance to
play and plays well
perceptions may change but for now it's
false and they're gonna ride with falls
and they're gonna see what they can get
out of falls and they're gonna hope that
foals can play like he did in 2017 when
the eagles won the super bowl and 2018.
what did foles do he brought an
overmatched eagles team to soldier field
and beat the bears
right
listen he's battle tested he knows his
offense you know he played you know they
got bill laser there right he's got some
history with him i believe but of course
more importantly the history with matt
nagy and understanding the andy reed
matinee offense which is you know going
to be a leg up i mean he'll know the
offense better than mitchell trubisky or
at least every bit is good and you know
get listen i'm gonna i'm not gonna sit
here and sugarcoat things
a big reason why the fan base in chicago
you know doubted mitchell trubisky to
your point early last year and things
like that i think a lot is because of
the chicago bears the chicago bears did
a horrible job of supporting him as
rookie year they put no talent around
him his second year you know they put
some talent around him got matinee in
there had a super bowl type defense but
matt nagy started off his career by
sending out a lot of under the radar
signals that trubisky can't be his guy
you know and you heard it i heard it
from a lot of people in the back
channels of the nfl and things like that
to where i feel like the bears
themselves set this narrative a little
bit and didn't support trubisky like
other top 10 quarterbacks would be
supported more times than not and that's
where i feel bad for mitchell trubisky
and you know that's part of the reason
why i just don't think they can start
him you start nick foles let him go
hopefully they win games if they don't
win games then you can bring mitch in to
save the day i remember you were salty
early in the 2018 season because of
nagi's comments about not being able to
use the full offense with trumpisky it
shows you got no faith in the guy and
you're undermining the guy right out of
the gates it was it was to start the
year it was the green bay packers you
know aaron rodgers hurt his knee and
came back and made all those great plays
on one leg it was that game one of the
first graphics they ever threw on the
board for that game was mitchell
trubisky running on the field with a
quote from matt nagy that said
can install my full offense with this
guy at quarterback i still got the
picture on my phone you know oh that's
what a great what a great way to start
the guy's career off by letting
everybody know that he can't execute
your full offense you know i want i hope
nick foles goes in there this year and
they put up a graphic of him and he has
a quote going matt nagy not as good as
the other offensive coordinators i've
been around you know i mean
that was a bullcrap thing and i did not
like that
well and it just showed that sometimes a
dysfunctional relationship starts off in
dysfunctional fashion and it leads to
dysfunctional places and that's where
the bears currently are you know i i
don't know what to think of the bears
this year i i did a thing yesterday for
our our uh nbcsn affiliate in chicago
and uh they wanted me to just talk
generally about how the team is improved
or not it's like i can't get past the
quarterback position i feel like it's
all going to hinge on that any other
changes you've made don't matter if the
quarterback position works the bears
will be better and if it doesn't it
won't period right well i i you know i
think that's certainly a big part of the
conversation the quarterback play and
the offense in general have to get
better you know i'm not trying to say
this right what i saw on film last year
from the chicago bears offense and maybe
mitch briskey is a reason why it was
like this but i didn't see a lot of
different the year before either where i
want it to me is one of the most
underwhelming unimaginative offenses in
the nfl so i'm not a huge fan of the
offense and yes the quarterback's not
doing a lot to raise a level of play
there altogether but you're right the
bears are one of those teams right it's
we see some talent in some certain spots
i mean the defense them getting robert
quinn you know signing back danny
trevathan you know i'm just trying to
look even artie burns at corner is a
nice addition to their secondary you
know they their defense is still going
to be one of the better ones in football
to your point mike it's all about the
offense you know and and you know what
does jimmy graham do they did get cole
quebec in the first round or second
round he's a first round type talent so
they're going to have some good tight
end play there in chicago this year but
can they run the ball can they protect
the passer can they create explosive
plays in the pass game those are all
things that just we didn't see from the
bears last year
something i found from mid-september
2018 when we were just learning that
patrick mahomes is going to be special
because we didn't know in 2017 because
he didn't play except for week 17 matt
nagy was with mahomes in 2017
making the jump to trubisky in 2018 and
that's just when people were starting to
realize maybe the bears got it wrong
taking trubisky over mahomes naggy said
that mahomes is doing better because
mahomes had a year in that offense he
was banging that drum that trubisky is
learning it and they're going to be
growing pains for him but mahomes had a
whole year to sit and study in that same
offense that's why he's coming out of
the gates so well and i think that
history has told us since then there are
other reasons why mahomes has performed
better than mitchell trubisky but but it
was a narrative that got locked in early
chris and and i really do think it kind
of shaped that relationship and it
becomes almost impossible to change the
fundamental nature of the relationship
when from the beginning there's this
sense that you're dealing with this guy
that just doesn't get it that has to be
spoon-fed that doesn't understand the
offense that i never can really do
everything i want to do and it just kind
of avalanches from there
it does it definitely does and that's
why i talked about you know too
the support system around a huge
investment as your second second
quarterback or second player off the
board in the nfl draft you know that
your job in making that investment is to
protect that investment and make it look
good or there then you're in trouble or
your butt's on the hot seat and that's
where i think the bears failed
themselves and failed mitch trubisky you
know again it's awesome and we know
patrick mahomes is another stratosphere
from mitchell trubisky but we also can't
forget patrick mahomes took over
a team that was a playoff caliber
football team was like a one and a two
seeds even years prior to that and then
also got to walk into a situation where
it's like hey i'm the quarterback whoa
we got the best tight end in football
and maybe the best weapon in football
and tyree kill so he really was put in a
position to succeed from the get-go the
bears there's it's year you're four for
mitchell trobisky and they're still
trying to figure out their offense and
figure out the talent and what they can
do who scares you on the bears offense
nobody there's a lot of good there's no
great and it's hard to be a great
quarterback when you got nobody on the
team that scares the defense other than
you know maybe you as a player that's
that's hard that's tough sledding
but chris i do give the bears credit
they didn't compound their mistake by
extending the contract right by a fifth
year they didn't pick up the fifth year
option worst case scenario is the good
problem to have where trubisky has a big
year and they're backed into a corner do
they use the franchise tag do they sign
them to a contract and remember this if
the salary cap drops in 2021 because of
the financial consequences of the
pandemic there's a chance that the
franchise tag next year will actually be
lower than what the fifth year option
salary would have been if the bears had
picked it up so they still have that in
their back pocket because the fifth year
option was 24 million in change right
now the franchise tag is 26 8
depending upon how far the salary cap
drops it it may be uh six and one half a
dozen of the others so look
the best case scenario for the bears
would be for trubisky to finally become
the guy that they thought he was gonna
be if that happens
you gladly franchise tag him and find a
way to keep him around and uh you know i
still think that it's a long shot
especially for week one for week one
it's gonna be nick foles and until nick
foles gets injured he's gonna have to
trubisky is gonna have to sit and watch
and wait for a chance to go prove that
uh everyone is wrong and that there
really is something there that we
haven't seen yet
yeah i agree i just think it's it's it
makes too much sense it's just too much
of a bullseye on mitch chubiski right
now if you make him a starter it's gonna
become a hot button topic not only in
chicago where it already is but
throughout the nation it's gonna be
under such a microscope it'll it'll you
know become part of a
a dysfunctional team really it really
will it'll make the team dysfunctional
is the better way to say that sorry um
so i'm with you i think you start nick
foles and you let him go until whether
he gets hurt or fails and then you can
bring trubisky off the bench
before we go let's fast forward by a
year yesterday i suggested that marcus
mariota would be a perfect backup to
take some hill in new orleans if taysom
hill has an offense structured for him
by sean payton how about trubisky as the
number two behind taysom hill think of
what trubisky can do
chris maybe true bit maybe trubisky's
second act will be as the back up to
taysom hill in new orleans and you think
about that that connection the ryan pace
came from new orleans
saw something in trubisky that was
shaped by everything pace learned while
working with mickey loomis and sean
payton so there's already something
there
that would make you that would make an
outsider think this is apparently sean
payton's kind of guy uh unless sean
payton just flat out lied to ryan pace
to throw him off the patrick mahomes
scent which is possible too but but you
think about skill sets think about what
guys
it's not out of the question to see
trubisky as taysom hill's backup in 2021
because obviously biscuit will be a
backup somewhere he won't be a star
right no exactly right he's a phenomenal
athlete you know and i'm glad you
brought it up because i think it's
something that kind of was was missed
last year you know remember he got hurt
early in the year and that really took i
think his ability or his aggressiveness
to run the football and yeah i i think
it's a very good thought by you mike or
you know you go somewhere and you back
up cam newton similar type theory right
where just again it's it's going to be
that offense to where yeah you're going
to throw it but we're going to take
advantage of your running the football
and your ability to move and do all of
that stuff too you know i i you know i
know you and i have had this
conversation before but you know
if you're going to drop some of these
running quarterbacks sometimes you got
to run them you can't wait until like oh
we'll run them when the playoffs start
well let me just check yep you didn't
make the playoffs so you never ran them
last year you know i i think you know
some of these teams need to push the
envelope a little bit with that
conversation with some of these guys
that have that dual thread ability
and if all else fails trubisky can go
play for the raiders because john gruden
is a quarterback [ __ ]
all right that's it for today what what
when's the next unbuttoned
we got it coming today two o'clock
taping it would be me and ahmed fareed
we're going to talk about news around
the nfl some backup quarterback
situations and got a few other fun
segments uh that we're gonna uh enjoy
today so that'll be good he's never
watched the godfather before i made him
watch it this weekend so he's giving me
a book report on the godfather
apparently ahmed he lives under a rock
and i'm trying to bring him out from
underneath that rock into the culture of
the world not even america just the
world
well i'll have you read a book and then
you can do a movie review on the book
the next day so
either way
but yeah yeah one of the only humans on
the planet who has not seen the
godfather who is at least 18 years old
so uh that's something we'll check that
out i got kevin colbert the steelers gm
coming up later today we'll have that on
pftpm we'll be back tomorrow hopefully
no technical glitches if they're gonna
happen the best time for them to happen
is right on the way out the door and you
did a nice job of landing the plane
thanks man you know i was i was taught
it's i was taught well by a pretty good
pilot so
i'm just glad i got it done i'm just
glad it wasn't my side i'm glad it was
your side and not my side
i was not put on earth to fly a plane so
uh don't worry me neither that's for
sure
all right uh everybody have a great day
we'll see you back here on wednesday
chris great work as always check us out
all day long at profootballtalk.com and
we'll see you tomorrow
yeah
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports